[Musik]
gedacht du bleibst bis zum Abend und
gehst beim Rainer und zum Fußball
schauen
[Musik]
danke sportselt das ist lieb
besser aber zum vollkommenen Glück
Herbert was man da noch fehlt ich glaube
du ahnst es eh jetzt gehörst du kleine
[Musik]
so komm mal Herbert das ist ja der
Wahnsinn du hast ja einen richtigen
Griff halt oh das ist gut
man glaubt ja du hast heimlich geübt
sorry jetzt reicht es wieder jetzt hast
du deine Schuldigkeit getan lieber
Götter Gott jetzt mache ich meinen
wohlverdienten Schönheitsschlaf
na ja
bitte leg mein Kollege zurück
ja mein herberte wird mir nie einen
Prosecco nachschenken und dreimal nicht
massieren
also komm jetzt zurück
aber die die Herrenuhr in der oberen
Schublade die kannst sehr gerne nehmen
die ist nämlich von seiner Ex und die
fand ich schon immer hässlich also die
Uhr und die Frau
[Musik]
einen Griff hat der Mann
sollte beim Jobwechsel nachdenken
[Applaus]
[Musik]